former deputy assistant to the president
sebastian Gorka you know you wrote this
book that we can defeat Isis when you
get to lone Wolf's territory dr. Gorka
it becomes that much more difficult how
do we know how are we able we have the
most sophisticated weaponry of
intelligence available to mankind is it
possible that we could find every one of
these lone wolves before people die late
today we can do much better we
absolutely can especially under the
presidency of Donald J Trump number one
we have to jettison this idea of a lone
wolf
lone wolf was invented as a phrase or
was made popular by the Obama
administration to make Americans
disconnected dots there has not been a
significant jihadi attacks in September
the 11th in the United States where one
person acted completely isolated from
everybody else even Major Nidal Hasan
the man who was by himself in fort hood
was in regular contact with Anwar
al-awlaki who blessed his attack on his
fellow servicemen so number one no more
political correctness that gets thrown
out of the window but I don't take an
issue with you I just think this is
important are there not people that in
the privacy of their own homes or not
you know somehow identifying with the
sick twisted evil cause are adopting oh
I'm gonna be a disciple of I'm going to
take orders from whoever gives them to
me
make it a tack on Halloween and then
acts independently you're saying we
should jettison that entire idea that
that doesn't exist yeah we should
jettison the idea that there's an
individual in their basement who one day
is an upstanding American citizen and
then a few weeks later just because they
went to a few websites they become a
jihadi never happened the closest we got
was that pathetic case of jihadi Jane
and that wasn't a serious case when you
look at serious plots that have occurred
there's always some connection either
the individual traveled to Pakistan to
the Middle East to Syria got training or
they were in touch with another human
being who indoctrinated them who Blair
their action against the infidel so
there's always there's a footprint
there's an electronic and a physical
footprint and we have to identify it
number one by understanding there's no
front line in this war like there were
in olden days there's no trench out in
France there's no front line in Germany
or in the Asia Pacific the front line
short is when you leave your house in
the morning whether you're going to a
Christmas party in an office in San
Bernardino whether you're going on a fun
run in Boston you have to be responsible
for your own safety use the Second
Amendment if you are trained and legally
capable to do so I know you believe in
it I believe in it and secondly even if
you don't have the mental 42 to carry a
gun to protect yourself and your loved
ones be aware of your surroundings and
when you see something suspicious say it
these attacks
take weeks and sometimes months to
prepare we know the San Bernardino
killers were undertaking suspicious
activity before the attack that their
neighbors refused to report for fear of
being called Islamophobes or racist that
has to end you you see something you say
something because you could be saving
lives you know you say that and I want
to go in spite of all that has happened
and all the terror around the world will
put on I have four TVs in my radio
studio today as this was all unfolding
live on radio and I look at a CA CNN
fake news chyron and it actually says
witness suspect was yelling god is great
in Arabic okay he said Allahu Akbar so
somebody fake news CNN there is this
fear remember in the case we had the one
case where the neighbors saw these guys
working late at night and didn't want to
say anything and I think your point is
well-taken
let me ask this question we have talked
at length about the misuse and the great
sophistication and the weaponry of our
intelligence community every phone call
I was told by Bill Binney 34-year
veteran NSA every phone call every email
every text message is literally being
monitored by our intelligence we have
the capability of picking it up
all right can we legally can we thread
the needle constitutionally unreasonable
search and seizure can we thread that
needle and monitor what people say
without getting into people's private
lives because we've seen the dangers
with with surveillance and unmasking and
leaking you know raw intelligence
general Flynn a victim of this himself
right we have we have the best
intelligence community in the world but
because we love our technology we have a
propensity to make the haystack bigger
we're looking for needles in the
haystack and we just we collect more and
more data and it doesn't necessarily
make us smarter the focus on the
individual terrorists is as far as I'm
concerned the wrong way to go
that's mowing the grass the real center
of gravity in the jihadi movement are
the ideologues the people who on Twitter
on Facebook aren't banned by the way
removed but have 40,000 followers 50,000
followers that's where we have to start
we have to respect the photos let people
the people who feed it they'll still
strap bombs on their own children in the
name of Allah and promise them 72
virgins they themselves won't do it but
they'll encourage everyone else I'm
networker you stay with us stay right
there